your [__] coward you're sitting there
in a corner just going thank God it's
him and not me I'm not going to say
anything because I don't want to get in
trouble
shame on you you are pathetic and gross
Alfie Brown apologizes for using the
n-word seven times in resurfaced routine
a white I mean yeah because we couldn't
work that out from the [__] picture
you [__] yeah it was white though yeah
stand-up clubs in the capital are now
Under Pressure to de-platform Alfie
brown with one venue already refunding
tickets for his show on Saturday now
guys at this point Anton hides us for a
second it is very important to remind
you there is no cancel culture it
doesn't exist anyone who says there's a
problem with free speech and comedy is
lying and we live in a beautiful
wonderful tolerant Society it was
recorded in 2015 and years ago I
realized my what would I say my mistake
and made every attempt to remove it not
because I was scared of it being found
although I was absolutely terrified of
it being found but because it was wrong
yeah of course Alfie what do you think
about this mate I've he's absolutely
disgraceful
when you do that you when you do a
routine with that word
it's a comedic equivalent over and out
of an atomic bomb you best Atomic bum
bum yeah it's an atomic bomb it's a trap
come in and shove special Rockets yeah
to show you how to be real men fan
please fall in a nuclear reaction no
right it's an atomic bomb you best be
sure you to know what you're doing
otherwise if it goes off things are
going to turn very ugly very very
quickly you've got to be if you're gonna
use that word in the modern environment
you better have a [__] killer routine
behind you yeah Alfie didn't to be fair
it was eight years ago and look the
point we always make is in order to get
a killer routine it sometimes takes
years yeah of working on it and the only
way you can work on it is to stay in
front of other people and that means
that at some point what will eventually
become a killer routine will not be a
killer routine it'll be quite [__] yeah
right so in order for a comedian to work
through a routine involving that sort of
word sometimes they're gonna say uh are
going to say it in a way that's not that
funny I didn't think it was particularly
funny in this instance but why are you
trying to cancel this guy eight years
it's not like he's running around doing
that now no and here's the worst part
right the way that the these comedians
have piled in on him
comedians these are people who you would
think free speech and the ability to
express oneself without censorship it
should be important to them these are
the people who are basically driving
this and you see this is what comedians
don't understand and I know a lot of
those comedy mentions watch our show so
this is for them what they've done to
Alfie now is they've gone through every
podcast he's been on every routine he's
ever published every joke he's ever told
and what they found is he made a joke
about being a pedophile as every
comedian has done at some point he made
a joke about something else right
they've gone through his back catalog
and they've basically dug up everything
that can be made to look offensive out
of context and if comedian is done band
together and don't defend people's
rights to make a joke and not be
successful with it to make a [__] joke
to say something offensive all that will
happen is one by one every single one of
you is going to find yourself in this
position and uh one of our best mates in
comedy who We're Not Gonna name uh who's
got a quite a successful podcast Etc he
won't come out and say anything because
he himself uh nearly got canceled for
making a joke about disabled people
right and went on a [__] course and
they're all [__] you're all [__]
none of you are speaking up for this guy
right even though he's on the right side
of politics and whatever
because you're a bunch of [__] and
you will be next this is the point that
comedians don't understand it doesn't
matter how woke you are you have called
a joke at some point the joke that is
going to cancel your career is out of
out there somewhere and if you continue
to Pander to all these woke Pricks in
the comedy industry and pretend that
there's no cancer culture and pretend
there's no censorship in comedy and
pretend that comedy in Britain this is
Bastion of free speech and you can say
and do whatever you want you're all
going to get [__] canceled you're
never going to be woke enough for these
people they will all come for you it
doesn't matter how nice you are what you
say how you say and watch what happens
to Alfie now he was one of you he was
woke he was cool he was you know fitting
in with all of you and look at the way
you are behaving towards him now your
[__] cowards you're sitting there in
a corner just going thank God it's him
and not me I'm not going to say anything
because I don't want to get in trouble
and when they come for you that is
exactly what all the other comedians are
going to do all those people you think
your friends they're not your [__]
friends the moment someone comes for you
they're all gonna hide just like you're
hiding now because you're all a bunch of
[__] man up and actually do the
material you want to do create things
that give you independence from the
comedy circuit because they will destroy
you just like they're gonna destroy
Alfie now and also stand up for your
friends have a little bit of integrity
and turned up for
people talking to comedians yeah but you
won't do that because your career is far
more important to you getting on a TV
show that's watched by six people is far
more important to you than having a
sense of integrity that's why when you
when we went on Rogan and I said what I
said and you all piled in on us and you
said that I was a or a racist and white
supremacist people who are actually
meant to be my friends were liking these
tweets even though you knew it was
[__] even you know even though you
know that I'm not a racist but you still
did it because you wanted to look good
because you wanted to Virtue signal well
here's the thing you're next it's all
right you can all come on trigonometry
one day when you get canceled exactly
maybe then you might actually get some
followers
[Laughter]
it just goes to show it actually that we
were right we were right and we were
gaslit from the moment we started this
you're these you're that you you know
your audience is far right blah blah
blah blah blah and look at you now
you're trapped on a sinking ship
surrounded by the rats that you've
surrounded yourself with yeah who I
can't wait to stand by while you get
canceled in the public eye yeah because
then it might have been an opportunity
to get on mock the [__] oh sorry that's
been canceled the mass repo sorry that's
been Frankie Bosnia oh that's been
canceled
oh let's go let's go and pry up the
creek like I used to on the weekends oh
no you can't do that because uh you said
a joke eight years ago so that's
canceled
and I'm going to tell you something
right now all those comedy clubs as well
that are just Embrace this ideology and
capitulate they're going to be the next
ones to go because nobody wants to
[__] watch that [__] and the worst
ones and I'm telling you right now well
it's not in the bills and all the those
other people who've come out I mean they
are what they are and I'm not even going
to say the word right it's the white
liberals they're the ones who are the
absolute worst they're the worst ones
out of all of them they're not liberal
they're not liberal they're working
they're working different and it's not
even that you work if you want to be
woke fair enough do you have your
political opinion have your way of
looking at the world that isn't the
problem the problem is is that you jump
on board and you celebrate a person's
career being destroyed oh no Alfie he's
actually a good blog he's a nice guy and
he's been toiling at the comedy cold
face since he was 18 years old he's 35
now he's making Headway he's selling out
some tours into you know in like 100
seat of rooms have been on TV to be fair
to him he's going to sell out some tours
again it'll be a very different type of
audience yeah you're coming on the
trigonometry tour Alfie
especially comedians you understand how
jokes work you understand how writing
jokes work you know you know that no bit
of material comes out of you fully
formed you know that when eight years
ago the sensitivities around race were
not what they are now it was very common
for people back then to be playing with
these sort of things for comedic
purposes right for comedians to stay
silent when this is happening to a mate
of theirs you're just [__] cowards
you're absolute cowards and you take a
perverted thrill in Delight in some of
them do I think most of them are just
scared the ones that are engaged in this
actively yeah they're taking a perverted
thrill and delight at the destruction of
your colleague's career shame on you you
are pathetic and gross Alfie Brown
welcome to trigonometry
all right let's catch up on the super
chats put a [__] helmet we were
slagging comedians off for so long I was
completely lost track of time but yeah
it's an enjoyable thing oh my